Last week, I told you about equilibrium, which
is proof,
if you ever needed proof, that the universe
is trying to mess with us,
because even though we think and talk about chemical reactions as being a straightforward process,
often times they're also going backwards.
At the same time, the reactants are combining to form products like nitrogen and hydrogen to make ammonia,
or hydrogen and fluorine to make hydrogen
fluoride.
The products are also breaking back apart
into the reactants.
So there's a sweet spot.
One particular ratio of reactants to products where the products form at the same rate that they break down.
When a reaction hits that spot, it's said
to be in its equilibrium state.
A bit of a kick in the head.
But of course you're not totally at chemistry's
mercy;
you can tinker with chemical equilibrium by
altering the concentration of the substances
and their temperature and if they're gases,
the pressure on them.
For example, adding pressure to the Haber
Process that we use to create ammonia essentially
shifts the position of equilibrium,
so the result of the reaction is more ammonia
being produced than nitrogen and hydrogen.
But, wouldn't it be a lot more helpful if
you knew
how much pressure you'd have to add to produce
the exact amount of ammonia you needed,
or how much hydrogen fluoride it takes to
refine a certain volume of gasoline.
Math, of course, is the way to answer questions like these, so today I'm going to show you some simple,
totally non-scary calculations that will help
you get a handle on chemical equilibrium.
[Theme Music]
The first and most important thing you need to do equilibrium calculations is the equilibrium constant.
This number is unique for every reaction and
represents
a molar ratio of products over reactants when
a reaction is at equilibrium.
Equilibrium constants are easy to set up but
hard to explain,
so let's start with an example using this
obviously fake chemical equation.
The capital letters stand for the reactants
and the products
and the lowercase letters stand for their
coefficients.
The equilibrium constant, or Keq, is equal to the product of the molar concentration of the products
divided by the product of the molar concentration
of the reactants.
Each concentration is raised to the power
of its coefficient in the balanced equation.
Now this is important; we're using the coefficients
as exponents here
because we're multiplying all the products
and all the reactants,
not adding them like you would do in a balanced
equation.
Generations of students have messed up test scores by getting this part wrong, but you will not do that.
So again, it's the product of the products of the product of the reactants and the coefficients become exponents.
Actually pretty simple.
The square brackets in the formula are used
by chemists to represent molar concentration,
or molarity: moles of solute per liter of
solution.
These equilibrium constant equations and the
constants themselves
are one of the few places where you don't
need to write them with every number.
Just remember to convert everything into molarities
before plugging numbers into the equation.
One last thing before we do a calculation:
as we learned in the last episode,
a change in temperature changes the position
of equilibrium.
Therefore, the equilibrium constant is only
true for a specific temperature.
Constants are normally calculated at 25 degrees
Celsius, which is close enough for most situations,
but the temperature should always be mentioned
along with the constant.
Fortunately for us, chemists have already figured out the equilibrium constants for most common reactions.
Carbonic acid, for instance, which is basically
just carbon dioxide dissolved in water,
dissociates to form carbonate ions and hydrogen
ions.
You'll see this reaction again later when we talk in depth about carbon and the planet's carbon cycles.
More importantly, right now, the reaction is perfectly reversible with an equilibrium constant of 1.66 x 10^-17.
For this reaction, Keq equals the product of the molar concentration of the carbonate ion
and the molar concentration of the hydrogen
ion,
which is squared because hydrogen's coefficient
in the balanced equation is 2,
all divided by the molar concentration of
carbonic acid.
Now, let's not be boring and throw a bunch
of numbers around.
What you need to see is that the quotient on the right must always yield the same number because it's a constant.
So, if the amount of CO2 in the atmosphere increases leading to more H2CO3 in the earth's water,
the concentration of carbonate ions and/or hydrogen ions must also increase so the total will match the Keq.
You should also notice that any change to
the concentration of hydrogen ions
will have a huge effect on the denominator
because its square.
So an increase in hydrogen ions, like if the water were somehow acidified by an outside source,
would require a huge decrease in carbonate
ions or a huge increase in carbonic acid —
carbon dioxide pulled in from the atmosphere
to satisfy the equilibrium condition again.
We can attack this problem from another direction, too, depending on what information we have to begin with.
Chemists often know not only the equilibrium
constant for a reaction,
but also how much of each reactant is available.
And all they need to figure out is exactly how much of each substance will be present at equilibrium.
This type of calculation is easiest using
a format called a RICE table.
RICE stands for Reaction, Initial, Change,
and Equilibrium.
On the R line at the top of the table, we
write the chemical equation of reaction,
leaving space between each part so we'll have
room to add more information below.
On the I line we write the initial concentrations
of each substance.
Some of those will almost always be zero, since products generally aren't present until the reaction begins.
The C line is where we map out how much of
each substance will change during the reaction.
We often don't know exactly how much this
is until we do the math,
so we start out with x, where the amount is
unknown.
The E line is where we put the final result: how much of each substance will be present at equilibrium.
Since the final amount is just the initial
amount plus any changes that have occurred,
this line is the sum of the initial line and
the change line.
Let's do this for hydrogen fluoride, or HF, an integral part of the process of refining gasoline.
It can be formed in the gaseous state by an equilibrium reaction between hydrogen gas and fluorine gas.
Start by writing the balanced equation.
For our initial concentrations,
let's use 3.00 mol of H2 and 6.00 mol of F2
in a 3.00 liter container at a certain temperature.
That makes the initial concentration of H2
3 moles in 3 liters, or a 1.00 molar solution.
Similarly, the initial concentration of the
F2 is 6 moles per 3 liters, or 2 molar.
No HF has formed yet, so it's initial concentration
is 0.
So what we're trying to figure out is how
much of the hydrogen and the fluorine
will react to form hydrogen fluoride under
these conditions.
So we'll call the change 'x' for now.
Since 1 mole of H2 and 1 mole of F2, combine
to form 2 moles of HF.
We can say that the H2 and F2 will each lose 'x' moles per liter while the HF gains 2x moles per liter.
That's on the change line of your table.
So that leaves the equilibrium line where
you write your totals.
For H2 we have a total of 1.00 - x molar.
For F2 the total is 2.00 - x.
For the HF the total is 2x molar.
Now we apply these figures to our formula
for the equilibrium constant.
Based on the table in the back of my textbook, the Keq for this reaction is 115 at the given temperature.
We plug in the numbers from our RICE table
and solve for x.
And we end up with this. Which you probably
recognize as a quadratic equation.
Just so you know that doesn't happen with every equilibrium calculation, but it's an extremely common result.
To solve the quadratic equation we have to
use the quadratic formula.
And to do that we have to think of the coefficients
of our equation as a, b, and c in that order.
Then we plug them in the corresponding positions
in this formula:
-b +/- the square root of b2 - 4ac, all divided
by 2a.
Once we finally get all the numbers in the
right places,
it becomes a matter of grinding through some
basic algebra.
And because of the way the quadratic formula
works, we'll get 2 possible answers.
To figure out which one is the right one,
think back to the beginning of the problem.
I said the initial concentration of the H2 was 1 molar, and the initial concentration of the F2 was 2 molar.
And x is the amount that each one lost, right?
Well neither the H2 nor the F2 could possibly
lose 2.13 moles per liter
when they both started with less than that
already.
So clearly, the correct answer has to be 0.968
molar.
Using that then, we can calculate the actual
equilibrium amounts for each substance.
At equilibrium, under these specific conditions
the concentration of HF is 2x,
or 2 x 0.968,
which equals 1.94 molar.
The concentration of hydrogen will be 1 - 0.968
or 0.032 molar.
And the concentration of fluorine will be
2 - 0.968 or 1.03 molar.
As we learned last week, those values can
be shifted.
For instance, to maximize the hydrogen fluoride production by adding or removing some of the substances.
Or by changing the pressure or temperature
on the system.
That's why these calculations are so valuable
to scientists.
Just a little bit of algebra allows us to
maximize the benefit that we receive from
the things that nature is already doing anyway.
If the universe really is try to take advantage of us, we've certainly figured out how to take advantage right back.
So the next time you're wondering why you
learned this stuff in math class, now you know.
Thanks for watching this episode of Crash
Course Chemistry.
Today you've learned some mathematical tools to help us make more efficient use of equilibrium reactions in real life.
You've learned how to calculate an equilibrium
constant, Keq.
You've learned how to calculate the equilibrium conditions of reactions just from knowing their initial conditions.
And you've learned that a RICE table isn't
just a place where you eat sushi.
And you may even have learned a little bit
about the quadratic equation.
This episode was written by Edi González.
The script was edited by Blake de Pastino.
And our chemistry consultant was Dr. Heiko
Langner.
It was filmed, edited, and directed by Nicholas Jenkins. The script supervisor was Katherine Green.
The sound designer is Michael Aranda. And
our graphics team is Thought Café.